This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedant. In the 1960s, Madison Avenue was trying to come up with a campaign for a major consumer brand. On a ranch in Wyoming, advertising executives discovered a cowboy who seemed like a perfect fit. His name was Darrell Winfield, and he came across as tough, masculine, self-reliant. His face was soon plastered on billboards across America, Asia and Africa. Ads showed him riding across rugged landscapes, often in silhouette. As violins played hauntingly in the background, the slogan on screen read, This is Marlborough Country.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。20世纪60年代，麦迪逊大道正在为一家大型消费品牌构思广告活动。在怀俄明州的一个牧场里，广告高管们发现了一位看起来非常合适的牛仔。他的名字叫达雷尔·温菲尔德，他给人的印象是坚毅、阳刚、自立。很快，他的脸就出现在了美国、亚洲和非洲的广告牌上。广告展示了他骑马穿过崎岖地貌的画面，通常是以剪影的形式呈现。伴随着背景中凄美的提琴声，屏幕上的标语写道：“这就是万宝路的世界。”
the slogan on screen read, This is Marlborough country. The campaign to sell Marlborough cigarettes was one of the most effective in the history of advertising. It sold more than just tobacco products. It sold an image of the American West. In urban neighborhoods across the United States and in crowded cities and poor villages around the world, it offered a seductive vision of independence, self-sufficiency, and freedom.
屏幕上的标语写道：“这就是万宝路的世界。”这场推销万宝路香烟的广告活动是广告史上最有效的活动之一。它卖出的不仅仅是烟草产品，它卖的是一种美国西部的形象。在美国各地的城市社区，以及世界各地拥挤的城市和贫困的村庄里，它提供了一种关于独立、自给自足和自由的诱人愿景。
The Marlboro Man told two great lies. The first caused untold sickness, disease, and death. Cigarettes are responsible for millions of deaths from lung cancer, heart disease and emphysema. But our story today is about the second great lie. The Marlboro Man and countless other media creations like it suggest that our best lives are lived when we can be free of the cares, the concerns and the constraints of other people. and the constraints of other people. Today, we unpack how those themes have been woven into our lives, in the attitudes we have, and in the choices we make.
万宝路男人讲述了两个弥天大谎。第一个谎言导致了无数的疾病、痛苦和死亡。香烟是导致数以百万计的人死于肺癌、心脏病和肺气肿的罪魁祸首。但我们今天的故事是关于第二个弥天大谎。万宝路男人和无数类似的媒体创作都在暗示，当我们能够摆脱他人的牵挂、担忧和束缚时，我们才能过上最好的生活。今天，我们将剖析这些主题是如何融入我们的生活，融入我们的态度，以及融入我们所做的选择中的。
It's also the start of our annual summer series, U2.0. As we do every year, we will share ideas and wisdom that can help you to thrive and to grow. Unlocking the science of meaningful relationships. This week on Hidden Brain. Psychologists and social scientists have wrestled with the themes of connection and independence for decades. Human beings need one another and crave friendship and social approval. But we also value solitude, silence,
这也是我们年度夏季系列节目“U2.0”的开端。正如我们每年所做的那样，我们将分享能够帮助你茁壮成长和进步的理念与智慧。解锁有意义的人际关系背后的科学。本周在《隐藏的大脑》中。几十年来，心理学家和社会科学家一直在探讨联系与独立这两个主题。人类需要彼此，渴望友谊和社会认可。但我们也珍视孤独、宁静，
and being left alone in peace. At the University of Chicago, psychologist Nicholas Epley has spent many years thinking about this tension. He has come up with innovative ways we can be the best version of ourselves. Nick Epley, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thanks, Shankar. Great to be here.
以及独自享受和平。在芝加哥大学，心理学家尼古拉斯·埃普利花了很多年时间思考这种张力。他提出了一些创新的方法，让我们能够成为最好的自己。尼克·埃普利，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢，尚卡尔。很高兴来到这里。
Nick, you live on the outskirts of Chicago and you take a long train ride into the city to go to work every day. For years, you followed an unvarying protocol on the train. What did you do? Oh, I just sat there and ignored everybody. I'd read a book, I'd listen to music, I'd scroll through my phone looking at the news, the kind of thing that everybody else does. Sit down, you leave other people alone. ["The Last Supper"]
尼克，你住在芝加哥郊区，每天都要坐很长时间的火车进城上班。多年来，你在火车上一直遵循着一种不变的规程。你都做些什么？哦，我只是坐在那里，无视所有人。我会看书、听音乐、刷手机看新闻，做每个人都会做的那种事。坐下来，不去打扰别人。 [《最后的晚餐》]
So one morning many years ago, you stepped onto the train as usual, but something struck you for the first time. What did you find yourself thinking about that day, Nick? Yeah, I remember this day like a lightning bolt to the brain. I actually had been on that particular day writing a chapter describing how we're made happier and healthier by reaching out and connecting with others by being social. And yet I kind of looked up that morning and realized for the first time, it just kind of hit me that here we are, highly social creatures with brains
那么，多年前的一个早晨，你像往常一样上了火车，但有什么东西第一次触动了你。那天你发现自己在想什么，尼克？是的，我记得那天就像一道闪电击中了大脑。事实上，那天我正在写一章内容，描述我们如何通过接触和联系他人，通过社交来变得更快乐、更健康。然而那天早上我抬头看了一眼，第一次意识到，它就这样击中了我：我们是高度社会化的生物，拥有大脑，
uniquely adapted for connecting to the minds of others. And yet we're all sitting here ignoring each other. And that struck me as bizarre. I guess no one really wants to be that guy that opens up a conversation that's an unwanted conversation. Right. That guy that makes you wanna put a pencil through your ear or wish you'd brought headphones with you, that guy who drives you nuts.
大脑天生就是为了与他人的思想建立联系而进化的。然而我们却都坐在这里无视彼此。这让我觉得很怪异。我想没人真的想成为那个开启一段不受欢迎对话的人。没错。那个让你想拿铅笔戳耳朵，或者希望自己带了耳机的人，那个让你抓狂的人。
And so people sit there and are quiet. So on this day you get on the train, you notice the contrast between what you're writing about in the book and what you're seeing in the train compartment. What happens next? Well, I decided to run an experiment that day. I essentially enrolled myself in my own experiment, at least as a sample of one.
所以人们坐在那里保持安静。那么在那一天，你上了火车，注意到了你书中所写的内容与你在车厢里所见之间的反差。接下来发生了什么？嗯，我决定那天做一个实验。我基本上把自己注册成了自己的实验对象，至少作为一个样本。
And I decided I'd try to have a conversation with somebody that morning. I'd take an interest in somebody else. I'm not, I'm probably not the most inviting looking person. I'm kind of a big guy. I'm a man. And so typically people will get on the train and they'll take the seats that are open eventually until there are no seats left, at which point somebody will have to sit next to me. So eventually all the seats are taken and a woman comes and sits down next to me. She's an African American woman in probably her mid fifties or so, I would guess.
我决定那天早上试着和某人交谈。我会对别人表现出兴趣。我可能不是一个看起来最容易接近的人。我个子比较大，是个男人。所以通常人们上火车后会坐空位，直到没有座位为止，这时就不得不有人坐在我旁边。所以最终所有的座位都坐满了，一位女士过来坐在我旁边。我猜她是一位非裔美国女性，大概五十岁出头。
She had on a bright red hat. I remember that very vividly. She sat down next to me and I decided I'm going to try to get to know a little something about her and So I said the first thing that came to my mind which was a joke, but a compliment at the same time. I Complimented her on her hat. I said how much I liked it and that I had one just like it and We both chuckled. I mean it wasn't look. It's probably not the best joke you've ever heard But that got the conversation started from there. It just went. We talked about our careers and our jobs and what we did for a living, but also whether
她戴着一顶亮红色的帽子。我记得非常清楚。她坐在我旁边，我决定试着了解她一点，所以我说了脑海中浮现的第一件事，那是一个笑话，但同时也是一个赞美。我称赞了她的帽子。我说我有多喜欢它，而且我正好也有一顶一模一样的。我们俩都笑了。我的意思是，看，这可能不是你听过的最好的笑话，但它确实开启了对话。从那以后，对话就自然而然地进行了。我们谈论了我们的职业、工作以及我们靠什么谋生，但也谈到了
this was really what we wanted to do for a living. I remember her feeling sort of stuck in her job and it wasn't quite what she wanted to do and thinking about making a change. She talked a little bit about her family, how she needed support, her family. And you know, the conversation went really fast. It was about a half an hour trip. It was over really quickly. I was struck by that. And as I got up to leave, I thanked her for taking time to talk to me. She seemed delighted to have talked to me. And as I walked off the train, I remembered two feelings. One, that it felt nice. It was nicer than what I'd have normally done that morning,
这是否真的是我们想从事的职业。我记得她感觉在工作中有些受困，那并不是她真正想做的事情，她也在考虑做出改变。她谈了一些关于家庭的事，谈到她如何需要支持。你知道，对话进行得非常快。那是一段大约半小时的旅程。很快就结束了。我对此印象深刻。当我起身离开时，我感谢她花时间与我交谈。她似乎很高兴能和我聊天。当我走下火车时，我记得有两种感觉。第一，感觉很好。这比我那天早上通常会做的事情要好，
which was probably scroll through the news. But the other thing I remembered was that it was surprisingly nice. I was surprised by that, surprised by how nice it was. There was another time in Nick's life when he found himself surprised by the effect of talking to strangers. He and his wife Jen were expecting a baby. Doctors had run some tests and told Nick that his daughter was likely going to have a genetic disorder. I remember Jen
那通常是刷新闻。但另一件事我记得是，它好得令人惊讶。我对此感到惊讶，惊讶于它竟然如此美好。尼克的生活中还有一次，他发现自己对与陌生人交谈的效果感到惊讶。他和妻子简当时正在期待一个宝宝。医生做了一些检查，告诉尼克他的女儿很可能患有遗传性疾病。我记得简
Met me in the breezeway of the house when I got home and she told me That it was likely that her daughter had Down syndrome And I remember It almost felt like I was hitting the chest. I kind of fell back Against the wall. It was of fell back against the wall. It was a shock. It was unexpected. At first, all that Nick wanted was to be left alone
在我回家时在门廊迎接我，她告诉我，女儿很可能患有唐氏综合症。我记得那感觉就像有人重重地打在我的胸口。我向后倒在墙上。那是一种冲击。那是意料之外的。起初，尼克想要的只是独自一人，
with his shock and confusion. He couldn't bear to talk to anyone else. Whenever you experience a shock like this, you look inward. It's a little bit hard to reach out to people, not quite sure what to talk about or what to say, and so my first instinct was to try to figure this out myself, figure out what best to do, how best to approach this. In time, however, Nick and Jen did reach out to other parents who had children with special needs. They quickly discovered that strangers were not only willing to talk, but had insights
带着他的震惊和困惑。他无法忍受与任何人交谈。每当你经历这样的冲击时，你就会向内看。向别人伸出援手有点困难，不太确定该谈论什么或说什么，所以我的第一直觉是试着自己解决这个问题，弄清楚最好的做法，最好的应对方式。然而，随着时间的推移，尼克和简确实联系了其他有特殊需求孩子的父母。他们很快发现，陌生人不仅愿意交谈，而且还有一些见解，
that felt surprisingly useful. It was actually pretty stunning. Pretty much every person we talked to at some point in the conversation use the same word to describe their experience. They all at some point use the word blessing to describe the experience of having a child with Down syndrome, that they all considered it to be a major blessing in their lives, one that opened their eyes to a new way of living that they hadn't seen before, that gave them a new perspective on life that they hadn't had before, that brought their family together in a way they
感觉出奇地有用。这实际上相当令人震惊。我们交谈过的几乎每个人在对话的某个时刻都用了同一个词来描述他们的经历。他们都在某个时刻用“祝福”这个词来描述拥有一个唐氏综合症孩子的经历，他们都认为这是他们生命中的一大祝福，它让他们睁开眼睛看到了一种他们以前从未见过的新生活方式，给了他们一种以前从未有过的生活视角，以一种他们以前
would not have guessed before. And for me, hearing these stories from these families, hearing what it was actually like, getting their perspective directly, was very reassuring for me to know that we could do this. Six months into the pregnancy, Jen suffered a miscarriage. Both she and Nick were devastated. Again, they turned to others for guidance and perspective. In a few months, based on the experience of other parents who had suffered similar tragedies,
无法预料的方式将他们的家庭凝聚在一起。对我来说，听到这些家庭的故事，听到真实的情况，直接获得他们的视角，让我感到非常安心，知道我们能够做到这一点。怀孕六个月时，简流产了。她和尼克都悲痛欲绝。他们再次向他人寻求指导和视角。几个月后，基于其他经历过类似悲剧的父母的经验，
they decided to do something they would not have dreamed of doing months earlier. They decided to adopt a child with Down syndrome. Jen had done some research and learned that earlier. They decided to adopt a child with Down syndrome. Jen had done some research and learned that it might be possible to adopt a child from China. There's quite a community of people who have done this. And we had a lot of conversations before we moved ahead with this.
他们决定做一件几个月前做梦也想不到的事情。他们决定领养一个患有唐氏综合症的孩子。简做了一些研究，了解到早些时候。他们决定领养一个患有唐氏综合症的孩子。简做了一些研究，了解到从中国领养一个孩子可能是可行的。有一个相当大的群体做过这件事。在我们推进这件事之前，我们进行了很多对话。
But I would say not so much to reassure us that this was the right thing for us to do at this time, but rather to learn more about how this would actually happen and how long this would take. And did you end up adopting a child from China? We did. She's a blessing, Shankar. Her name is Lindsay. She is in first grade.
但我会说，与其说是为了让我们确信这是我们当时应该做的正确事情，不如说是为了更多地了解这实际上会如何发生，以及这需要多长时间。你们最终从中国领养了一个孩子吗？是的。她是一个祝福，尚卡尔。她的名字叫琳赛。她现在上一年级。
She's eight years old now. This is five years ago that we brought her home. We took all of our kids to China when we brought Lindsay home with us and it's been the most amazing thing that Jen and I have done together in our lives so far. I don't think we would have gotten to the position where we were open or you'd even thought about bringing Lindsay into our lives without reaching out and connecting with other people to essentially be reassured that it would not just be something we could do, but that it'd be a blessing for us. I keep hearing those words echoing in my mind over and over again
她现在八岁了。我们把她带回家已经是五年前的事了。当我们把琳赛带回家时，我们带着所有的孩子去了中国，这是简和我迄今为止在生活中一起做的最棒的事情。我不认为如果我们没有向其他人伸出援手并建立联系，我们就能达到那种开放的状态，甚至不会想到把琳赛带进我们的生活，本质上是为了得到保证，这不仅是我们能做到的事情，而且对我们来说将是一种祝福。我不断听到那些话在我的脑海中回荡，
that we heard from those families when we talked to them initially. In time, Nick came to see there was a pattern connecting these different stories. He fully expected he would feel better when he rode the train in silence, but he felt better when he talked to a stranger. He wanted to withdraw into himself when he learned his daughter would have Down syndrome, but when he reached out to strangers, those conversations unexpectedly changed the way he felt. He was not someone who imagined adopting a child with special needs, but talking to other people who had done this revealed to him something about himself that he did not know.
那是我们最初与那些家庭交谈时听到的。随着时间的推移，尼克开始看到这些不同的故事之间存在着一种模式。他完全预料到自己在沉默中乘坐火车会感觉更好，但他却在与陌生人交谈时感觉更好。当他得知女儿患有唐氏综合症时，他想退缩到自己的世界里，但当他向陌生人伸出援手时，这些对话出人意料地改变了他的感受。他不是一个会想象领养一个有特殊需求孩子的人，但与做过这件事的其他人交谈，向他揭示了他自己所不知道的一面。
When we come back, why we so often seek to walk alone or in silence, and the psychology of what happens when we resist this impulse. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. When University of Chicago psychologist Nick Eppley received word that the baby he and his wife were expecting had Down syndrome, his first impulse was to withdraw from others and go it alone.
当我们回来时，我们将探讨为什么我们经常寻求独自一人或在沉默中行走，以及当我们抵制这种冲动时会发生什么心理。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。当芝加哥大学心理学家尼克·埃普利得知他和妻子期待的婴儿患有唐氏综合症时，他的第一冲动是远离他人，独自面对。
But he eventually found great comfort and reassurance by hearing about the experiences of other parents. Over time, Nick came to see that this was not an isolated incident. Opportunities for connection present themselves to us every day. In his book, Mind-Wise, Why We Misunderstand What Others Think, Believe, Feel, and Want, he
但他最终通过倾听其他父母的经历，找到了巨大的安慰和保证。随着时间的推移，尼克开始看到这并非孤立事件。联系的机会每天都在我们面前呈现。在他的书《明智：为什么我们误解他人的想法、信念、感受和愿望》中，他
explores why our assumptions about people are off and off base. Nick, you became increasingly curious about a phenomenon that you started to call under-sociality. What is under-sociality, Nick? So, I'm kind of struck by what seems like a paradox that's right at the core of human life, that on the one hand, we, as human beings,
探讨了为什么我们对他人的假设往往是错误的和偏离基准的。尼克，你对一种你开始称之为“社交不足”的现象越来越好奇。什么是社交不足，尼克？所以，我被一种似乎是人类生活核心的悖论所触动，一方面，我们作为人类，
are deeply social, we're made happier and healthier by reaching out and connecting to other people, whether it's strangers or family and friends. And yet there are so many opportunities in daily life where we could reach out and connect with other people that we don't take. We have a compliment that comes to our mind that we don't share.
是深度社会化的，我们通过接触和联系他人，无论是陌生人还是家人和朋友，都会变得更快乐、更健康。然而在日常生活中，有太多的机会我们可以伸出援手并与他人建立联系，但我们却没有利用。我们脑海中浮现出一个赞美，但我们没有分享。
We feel gratitude to somebody that we don't express. We have somebody we could say hello to or talk to or even just smile to that we don't. We have meaningful things we want to know about other people and we don't ask them about it. We don't seem, at least it seemed to me, to be social enough for our own good. So, you started running experiments in the Chicago areas where you actually had commuters do what you did on the train that day. Walk me through one of these experiments. What did you ask your volunteers to do and what came of it? Yeah, so the very first one we did was in collaboration with Juliana Schroeder, one
我们对某人感到感激，但我们没有表达出来。我们可以向某人问好、交谈，甚至只是微笑，但我们没有。我们有想了解关于他人的有意义的事情，但我们没有问他们。我们似乎，至少在我看来，没有为了我们自己的利益而进行足够的社交。所以，你在芝加哥地区开始进行实验，让通勤者做你那天在火车上做的事情。带我了解一下这些实验之一。你让你的志愿者做什么，结果如何？是的，我们做的第一个实验是与朱莉安娜·施罗德合作，她当时是
of my amazing PhD students at the time, who's now at UC Berkeley. And we went down to Homewood, Illinois, the Metra train station there, which is actually just one stop to the north of where we live in Flossmoor. And we set up a sign on the way up to the train platform that recruited people to participate in an experiment if they were interested. And we handed them a $5 Starbucks gift card and then we randomly assigned them to do one of three things on the train that morning.
我出色的博士生之一，现在在加州大学伯克利分校。我们去了伊利诺伊州的霍姆伍德，那里的Metra火车站，实际上离我们居住的弗洛斯穆尔只有一个站的距离。我们在通往火车月台的路上竖起了一个牌子，招募有兴趣的人参加实验。我们给了他们一张5美元的星巴克礼品卡，然后随机分配他们在那天早上在火车上做三件事之一。
In one condition, we asked people to just do whatever they normally do on the train. In the next condition, this is our solitude condition, we ask people to keep to themselves, to just focus on their day ahead and not engage other people in conversation. And in the third condition, we ask people to do the thing that I did on the train that morning,
在一种情况下，我们要求人们只做他们在火车上通常做的事情。在下一种情况下，这是我们的孤独条件，我们要求人们保持独处，只专注于他们即将到来的一天，不要与他人进行对话。在第三种情况下，我们要求人们做我那天早上在火车上做的事情，
which was when somebody comes and sits down next to you, try to have a conversation. We then handed them an envelope that had their Starbucks gift card in it and a survey in it. And we told them at the end of your commute, fill out the survey, drop it back in the mail to us. And so, and so off, off they went. And what did you find? So we asked them on the survey a few different things. We asked them how pleasant was your
那就是当有人过来坐在你旁边时，试着进行对话。然后我们给了他们一个信封，里面有他们的星巴克礼品卡和一份调查问卷。我们告诉他们，在通勤结束时，填写调查问卷，把它寄回给我们。于是，他们就出发了。你发现了什么？所以我们在调查中问了他们几件不同的事情。我们问他们，你的通勤与平时相比有多愉快？这次通勤后你感觉有多快乐？你感觉有多悲伤？我们将这些合并成一个单一的综合指标，本质上是他们的通勤有多积极。我们发现，人们在与陌生人交谈时，实际上报告了最积极的体验。而在我们要求他们保持独处的孤独条件下，他们的体验最不积极；人们做他们通常所做事情的控制条件处于中间。尽管在随后的实验中，我们发现这通常更像孤独
commute compared to normal? How happy do you feel after this commute? And how sad do you feel? We collapsed these into a single composite, essentially, of how positive their commute was. And what we found was that people actually reported having the most positive experience when they talked to a stranger. And they had the least positive experience in the solitude condition, where we asked them to keep to themselves the control condition where people do whatever they normally did fell in the middle. Although in subsequent experiments, we found that usually that's more like the solitude
条件。我们进行了另一个实验，我们要求人们不要告诉我们他们在做这些事情后的真实感受，而是告诉我们如果他们处于这些条件中的每一种，他们认为自己会有什么感觉，本质上是预测他们会有什么感觉。当我们这样做时，我们发现人们实际上预测他们在联系条件下会有最不积极的体验，而在控制和孤独条件下会有最积极的体验。而这些预期恰恰是错误的。所以你在那之后不久在伦敦地铁系统进行了同样研究的一个版本。
condition. We conducted another experiment where we asked people not to tell us how they actually felt after doing these things, but to tell us how they thought they would feel if they were in each of these conditions, essentially to predict how they would feel. And what we found when we did this was that people actually predicted that they would have the least positive experience in the connection condition and the most positive experience in the control and the solitude condition. And those expectations were just precisely wrong. So you conducted a version of the same study in the London subway system some time after this.
据我了解，伦敦人在火车上交谈的意愿甚至比芝加哥人还要低。告诉我你发现了什么，我了解到这个实验是在关于人们是否应该在伦敦火车上交谈的辩论背景下进行的。是的，通过与BBC的合作，我们实际上能够在伦敦这样一个
My understanding is that folks in London want to talk to each other on the train even less than folks in Chicago want to do so. Tell me what you found and I understand that this experiment was coming in the context of some debate about whether people should be talking to one another on trains in London. Yeah, we were able, through a collaboration with the BBC, to actually run these experiments in a place
不以友好著称的地方进行这些实验。事实上，在我们进行这个实验之前不久，伦敦地铁乘客乔纳森·邓恩实际上发起了一场运动，试图鼓励伦敦地铁乘客互相交谈。他称之为“地铁聊天”，他分发了徽章，并开设了一个Twitter账号和一个Facebook页面，试图鼓励人们在火车上与陌生人接触和交谈。
that's not known for its friendliness, which is London. And in fact, not long before we ran this experiment, London tube writer, Jonathan Dunn, actually started a campaign trying to encourage London tube writers to talk to each other. He called it Tube Chat and he handed out buttons and he started a Twitter handle and a Facebook page trying to encourage people to reach out and talk to strangers on the train.
结果引发了绝对的叛乱。有一个替代的Facebook页面被建立起来，即“闭嘴地铁聊天”运动，他们分发了自己的徽章，劝阻人们与他人交谈，宁愿喝一品脱漂白剂也不愿与另一个人交谈，他们分发了这些东西。所以伦敦似乎不是我们进行这些实验的最友好的地方。但事实证明，伦敦人也是人类。就像我们在芝加哥发现的那样，那些被我们随机分配到联系
And absolute rebellion ensued. There was a, an alternate, um, Facebook page that was started up the shut up tube chat campaign, which handed out their own buttons that discourage people from talking to other people rather drink a pint of bleach than talk to another person where this button they handed this stuff out. So it didn't seem like London was the friendliest place for us to be running these experiments. And it turned out that Londoners are human beings too. And just like we found in Chicago, those folks who we randomly assigned to be in the connection
条件中的人，他们报告说通勤最积极，而那些处于控制和孤独条件中的人报告说通勤最不积极。现在，听到这些实验，我想象有些人会说，你知道，外向的人可能喜欢与陌生人交谈，但我们中间的内向者呢？你认为性格在这里起作用吗？
condition, they reported having the most positive commute, and those folks in the control and the solitude conditions reported having the least positive commute. Now, hearing about these experiments, I'm imagining that some people will say, you know, extroverted people might enjoy talking to strangers, but what about the introverts among us? Does personality play a role here, do you think?
所以我们在这些实验中测量了这一点，我们没有发现它起作用。这在我们的研究中并不独特。心理学家一直在做大量的实验，要求人们表现得更外向或更内向。非常一致的发现是，当人们真正这样做时，人们在表现得外向时比表现得内向时感觉更快乐，
So we've measured this in these experiments, and we don't find that it does. And that's not unique to our research. Psychologists have been doing lots of experiments where they ask people to behave more extrovertedly or morerovertedly or more introvertedly. And the very consistent finding is that when people actually do this, people feel happier when they act extroverted
这对于那些一贯外向的人和那些一贯内向的人来说同样适用。据我们所知，内向和外向重要的地方不在于人们的社交互动体验，而在于他们对社交互动的选择。
than when they act introverted. And that's just as true for folks who are consistently extroverted as it is for folks who are consistently introverted. As far as we can tell where introversion and extroversion matters is not in people's experience of social interaction, as much as it is in their choices of social interaction.
也就是说，外向者比内向者更频繁地选择接触和与他人互动。由于选择了接触，他们往往会稍微快乐一些。在很多方面，这看起来有点像体育锻炼，我们中的一些人选择比其他人锻炼得更多，尽管我们所有人，无论我们是否选择这样做，如果更频繁地锻炼，实际上都会更健康一些。我们的社交性似乎也是如此。
That is extroverts choose to reach out and engage with others a little bit more often than introverts do. And as a result of choosing to reach out, they tend to be a little bit happier. In many ways, it seems a little bit like physical exercise, that some of us choose to exercise more than others, even though all of us, regardless of whether we choose to or not, would actually be a little healthier if we exercised more often. Same thing seems to be true with our sociality as well.
所以如果你问我，如果我坐在普通的公共汽车、飞机或火车上，我周围有多少人会真正想和我交谈？我不会把这个数字定得很高。我想象大多数人想独处。现在你实际上研究过这个。
So if you were to ask me, if I was sitting on the average bus or plane or train, how many of the people around me would want to actually have a conversation with me? I would not put that number as being very high. I would imagine that most people want to be left to themselves. Now you've actually studied this.
你实际上测量了人们关于他们认为别人想和自己交谈多少的印象。现在你实际上研究过这个，你实际上测量了人们关于他们认为别人想和自己交谈多少的印象。你发现了什么？所以我们发现这是接触和与他人互动的巨大障碍，或者至少是其中之一，那就是相信别人不想和你交谈，因此你可能会被拒绝，或者这个人可能不感兴趣。所以在芝加哥的火车上以及随后的实验中，我们在芝加哥的公共汽车上进行了实验。人们认为火车上不到一半的人如果他们尝试的话会愿意和他们交谈。在伦敦，情况甚至更严峻。
You've actually measured that impressions that people have about how much they think other people wanna talk to themselves. Now you've actually studied this, you've actually measured that impressions that people have about how much they think other people want to talk to them. What do you find? So what we find is that this is the big barrier to reaching out and engaging with other people, or at least as one of them, is believing that other people don't want to talk to you and hence you might be rejected or this person might be uninterested. So on the trains in Chicago and in the subsequent experiment, we ran in buses here in Chicago. People thought less than half of the people on the train would be willing to talk to them if they tried. In London, it was even more grim.
他们认为伦敦火车上只有大约25%的人愿意和你交谈。25%的伦敦火车乘客愿意和你交谈。现在，至少有这样的信念概率，你可能也不会尝试与他人交谈。所以我认为这在一定程度上解释了为什么人们不愿意接触和互动。他们认为别人不想。所以你可以得到一整车的人从来没有尝试过和别人交谈，因为他们认为别人不想，然后从来没有发现他们实际上可能对此是错误的。
They thought only about 25% of folks on the train in London would be willing to talk to you. 25% of folks on the train in London would be willing to talk to you. Now with at least believed odds like that, you probably wouldn't try to talk to other people either. So I think that helps to explain in part why folks are reluctant to reach out and engage. They think other people don't want to. And so you could get a whole carload of people never trying to talk to somebody else because they think other people don't want to and then never finding out that they in fact might be wrong about it.
所以除了低估我们会享受对话的程度，我们在与陌生人交谈时会感觉多么积极之外，我们还低估了我们将从对话中学到多少东西。在这方面你发现了什么，尼克？比尔·奈，著名的科学人，曾经说过，你遇到的每个人都知道一些你不知道的事情。比尔·奈对此很有智慧。每个人都有一个故事要告诉你。每个人都经历过你没有经历过的有趣的事情。但请注意，当你看着某人时，你看不出这一点。
So besides underestimating how much we will enjoy a conversation, how positive we'll feel when we talk to strangers, we also underestimate how much we will learn from a conversation. What do you find on this front, Nick? Bill Nye, famous science guy, once said, everyone you will ever meet knows something you don't. And Bill Nye is wise about that. Everybody's got a story for you. Everybody has been through interesting experiences that you haven't been through. But notice when you look at somebody, you can't see that.
你看到的是一种空白。我们不知道我们会学到什么。所以当我们要求人们在与陌生人交谈之前预测他们将从这次对话中学到多少东西时，我们非常一致地发现，人们认为他们不会学到很多。而在对话之后，他们报告说学到了显著更多，既关于他们正在交谈的人，关于他们的个人细节，也关于一般的事情，
You see kind of a blank slate. We don't know what we'll learn. And so when we ask people before their conversations with the stranger to anticipate how much they're going to learn in this conversation, we find very consistently that people, they think they're not going to learn a whole lot. And after the conversation, they report learning significantly more, both about the person they're talking to, personal details about them, but also about things in general,
无论你在对话中谈论什么。它出奇地有信息量。那天晚些时候我采访了尼克，我和朋友在一家餐馆。坐在隔壁桌的是一群人，一个年轻人带着他的儿子。孩子可能三岁，我觉得他看起来很可爱。我应该告诉那个爸爸他的孩子有多可爱，我想。然后我说，我告诉一个陌生人我觉得他的孩子很可爱会很奇怪吗？尼克说类似的事情发生在他自己的女儿身上。他们俩在厨房里看着人行道
whatever it is that you happen to be talking about in the conversation. It's surprisingly informative. Later in the day I interviewed Nick, I was at a restaurant with friends. Sitting at the next table were a group of people and one young man had his son with him. The kid might have been three and I thought he looked adorable. I should tell the dad how cute his kid was, I thought. Then I said, will it be weird for me to tell a stranger I thought his kid was adorable? Nick said something along these lines happened to his own daughter. The two of them were in their kitchen looking out at the sidewalk
在他们家门前。有一个女人沿着人行道走过来，她有一种绝妙的气质。那是一个非常非常美丽的非洲式发型。她看起来简直太壮观了，西恩评论了它。我记得站在厨房里告诉她，走到前门去告诉她她看起来有多棒。我不认为我能用撬棍把她从那个位置撬开。
in front of their house. And there's a woman who came down the sidewalk who just had this fabulous air. It was just this beautiful, beautiful Afro. She just looks spectacular and Seon commented on it. And I remember standing in the kitchen there telling her, go to the front door and tell her how amazing she looks. And I don't think I could have budged her with a crowbar out of that position.
她只是，这感觉太奇怪了，去对某人说那样的话，去那样赞美。我认为这是“社交不足”的另一个例子。我们脑海中浮现出一个善意的想法。我们可以传递它。我们会让他们感觉很棒。然而，是的，这样做感觉有点奇怪。所以也许我们没有。同样，当你把人们放在一项研究中，实际上，你知道，强迫他们赞美别人时，你发现了什么？所以，在这些实验中，我们要求在芝加哥公共场所一起的人，
She was just, it was, it just felt so weird to go up and say something like that to somebody, to compliment like that. And I think that's another one of these examples of under-sociality. We have a kind thought come to mind. We could pass it along. We'd make them feel great. And yet, yeah, it feels a little weird to do that. And so maybe we don't. And again, when you put people in a study and in effect, you know, force them to compliment other people, what do you find? So in these experiments, we ask people who are out together at some public place in Chicago,
我们要求一个人写下关于他们在一起的这个人的赞美，或者有时是三个赞美，取决于我们正在进行的实验，他们因为某种原因从来没有和这个人分享过。然后我们要求他们预测当这个人读到这个赞美或这些赞美时会有什么感觉。然后我们把他们赞美的人带回来读那个赞美，他们报告了他们对它的真实感受，以及它有多尴尬或奇怪，这通常是障碍，对吧？
we ask one person to write down a compliment about this person that they're with, or sometimes three compliments depending on the experiment we're in, that they have just for whatever reason never shared with this person before. We then ask them to predict how the person's going to feel when they read this compliment or these compliments. We then bring the person they complimented back to read that compliment and they report how they actually felt about it and also how awkward or weird it was, which was often the barrier, right?
做这件事会很奇怪。我们非常一致地发现，听到赞美，即使我们知道它们对另一个人来说是积极的。当人们真正听到它们时，当人们真正读到它们时，它们比我们预期的要积极得多。事实上，这不仅仅是我们的研究，埃里卡·布斯比和凡妮莎·邦斯也有出色的工作。他们发现了与我们同时发生的类似事情，即当人们赞美陌生人时，他们感觉比赞美给予者预期的要好。
It's going to be weird to do this. And what we find very consistently is that hearing compliments, even though we know they're going to be positive to the other person. When people actually hear them, when people actually read them, they're even more positive than we expect they'll be. And in fact, this isn't just our research, but great work by Erica Boothby and Vanessa Bones. They found a similar thing concurrent with us that when people compliment strangers, they feel better than the compliment givers expect to.
这种效果似乎相当稳健。所以还有另一种赞美形式，我们许多人不愿意提供。这涉及的不是陌生人，而是我们自己生活中的人，我们非常亲近的人。那就是重复赞美的想法。所以也许你感谢某人为你做了一些好事，但他们下周又做了，下下周又做了。过了一段时间，你开始说，
The effect seems to be pretty robust. So there's another form of compliment that many of us are reluctant to offer. And this involves not strangers, but people in our own lives, people we're very close to. And that is the idea of the repeated compliment. So maybe you thank someone for doing something nice for you, but they do it again the next week and the week after. And after some time, you start to say,
嗯，也许重复的赞美，听起来会太多。你也在这方面做过研究，关于重复的赞美。你发现了什么，尼克？嗯，恐惧当然是，如果你告诉我的妻子她看起来有多棒，她的烹饪有多棒，
well, maybe the repeated compliment, it'll sound like it's too much. You've done research along these lines as well about repeated compliments. What do you find, Nick? Well, the fear, of course, is that you'll start to sound like a broken record if I tell my wife how great she looks and how wonderful her cooking is
她对孩子有多好，她在友谊中有多棒，无论什么，你就会开始听起来像一张坏掉的唱片。我只是，你知道，你不断给某人赞美，最终它会疲劳。你会适应它。认为这一点是合理的，因为我们确实适应了很多东西。在一个实验中，我们让人们写下五个赞美给他们当天在一起的人。下周，我们每天与下一个人分享其中一个赞美。在发送这些赞美之前，写下它们的人预测接收者在收到这些赞美时会感觉有多积极。我们还要求另一组人预测
and how wonderful she is with the kids and how great she is in friendships and whatever. I just, you know, you keep giving somebody compliments, eventually it's going to tire. You're going to adapt to it. And it's reasonable to think this because we do kind of adapt to a lot of stuff. In one experiment, we had people write down five compliments to somebody who they were with on a given day. And the next week, we shared one of those compliments each day with the next person. And before sending those compliments out, the people who wrote them anticipated how positive the recipient would feel receiving those compliments. And we also asked a separate group of people to anticipate
接收者在收到这些赞美时会有什么感觉。那些想象每天赞美这个人的观察者认为接收者会厌倦它。你知道，我明白了，你爱我，够了。事实证明，接收者，他们喜欢它，就像前一天一样。我们没有看到任何一致的减少
how the recipient would feel when they got these compliments. The observers who imagine complimenting this person every day thought the recipient would get tired of it. You know, I get it, you love me, enough. It turned out the recipients though, they liked it just as much as the day before. We didn't see any consistent decrease
在他们收到赞美时的积极程度，部分原因是每一个都是独特的。当东西不同时，你就不会适应它。它一直保持良好。所以你是一个喜欢，你知道，言行一致的人，所以你把这个研究发现带回了你自己的家庭，并提出了一个新的圣诞传统。告诉我你提出的传统是什么，以及它是如何进行的。
in how positive they felt receiving and compliment, in part because each one was unique. And when stuff is different, you don't adapt to that. Stays good all along. So you're someone who likes to, you know, walk the talk, and so you took this research finding back to your own family, and you proposed a new Christmas tradition. Tell me what the tradition was that you proposed and how it went down.
是的，所以任何熟悉基督教传统的人都会熟悉降临节日历的概念。这是一个你得到的东西，你每天打开一个小标签，直到12月1日圣诞节之前，每一天后面都有巧克力。嗯，今年我决定我们在家里尝试别的东西。我们会在我的家里做一个赞美日历，遵循同样的降临节传统，但不是每天打开巧克力，而是每天一个赞美。
Yeah, so anybody who is familiar with the Christian tradition will be familiar with the concept of an Advent calendar. It's a thing that you get where you open a little tag every day and there's chocolate behind every day up until Christmas starting December 1st. Well, this year I decided we would try something else in the family. We would do a compliment calendar in my family that followed the same sort of Advent tradition, but instead of opening up chocolate every day, it would be a compliment every day.
所以我要求每个人写下关于家里其他每个人的赞美，他们可以传递，他们写了四个，这样我们就可以在整个月里拉长它。所以他们把它写在一张纸上。我把它折起来，弯成一个环，然后把它串成一串这些环。
So I asked everybody to write down a compliment about everybody else in the family that they could pass along, and they did four of these so that we could stretch it out through the month. So they wrote it down on a piece of paper. I folded that up, bend it over into a ring, and then strung it together into a chain of these rings.
所以每一天，你都会撕下一个环，打开它，就会有一个赞美。结果如何？家人接受了这个想法吗？他们喜欢吗？我得说，在这个开始时并没有很大的热情。他们相当确信这不会进行得很好。
So every day, you'd tear off one of these rings, open it up, and there would be a compliment. And how did it go? Did the family embrace the idea? Did they love it? There was not great enthusiasm at the start of this, I would say. They were pretty confident that this is not going to go well.
而且我想我宁愿要巧克力而不是这些赞美。但一旦我们真正做了，它就很棒。我仍然保留着我们做这件事的第一年里的一些赞美，放在我家的办公室里。我每天在家工作时都会看它们。我想转换话题到另一种我们经常避免的社交互动。你在高中时有一位你非常爱戴的非凡老师。告诉我一点关于他的事，尼克。所以自2001年以来我一直是一名教授，甚至在那之前，你知道，我在
And I think I'd rather have chocolate instead of these compliments. But once we actually did it, it was great. I still have some of those compliments from that first year we did it sitting in my office at the house. I look at them every day when I'm working at home. I want to switch gears to another kind of social interaction that we often avoid. You had an extraordinary teacher whom you loved very much in high school. Tell me a bit about it, Nick. So I've been a professor since 2001 and even before then, you know, I was in
研究生院待了五年，在那之前在大学待了五年。多年来我见过很棒的老师，但我见过的最棒的老师，也是我当然有过的最好的老师，是爱荷华州锡达拉皮兹草原高中的一名乐队老师，那是我上高中的地方。他的名字叫克雷格·奥尼。奥尼先生是我见过的最有激情的老师。
graduate school for five years and was in college for five years before that. I've seen amazing teachers over the years, but the most amazing teacher I've ever seen and the best one I've certainly ever had was a band teacher at Cedar Rapids Prairie High School in Iowa, which is where I went to high school. Craig Onnie is his name. And Mr. Onnie was the most passionate teacher I've ever seen.
我们会在比赛中在场地上行进，你可以听到奥尼先生在看台上用他自己的声音大喊，没有任何放大。他非常热情和鼓励，特别是对一群孩子，特别是像我这样的。我不是一个容易教的孩子。我根本不在乎参加乐队。我大部分时间都在那里玩乐和胡闹。他不在乎。无论如何，他都激发了我们最好的一面。
We would march on the field in competitions and you could hear Mr. Onnie yelling from the stands with his own voice, not amplified in any way. And he was just so enthusiastic and encouraging, particularly for a bunch of kids, particularly like me. I was not the easiest kid to teach. I did not care to be in band much at all. I was mostly there to have fun and screw around. And he didn't care. He brought the best out of us no matter what.
你有机会告诉他吗？你知道，我从来没有。部分原因是当我在高中时，我把他视为理所当然。直到我花了很多年观察其他人，你知道，他们自己也是很棒的老师，但仍然没有达到那个水平，我才意识到他有多棒。所以直到我变老了，我才真正欣赏他有多伟大。而到那时，他已经退休了，我不确定如何接触并向他表达这一点。
Did you have a chance to tell him that? You know, I never have. Part of it is that I took him for granted when I was in high school. And it wasn't obvious to me just how amazing he was until I spent so many years watching other people, you know, being amazing teachers in their own right, but still not reaching that level. So it wasn't until I got older that I really appreciated just how great he was. And by that time, he had retired, and I wasn't sure how to reach out and express that to him.
你曾经进行过一项研究，要求志愿者给他们生活中的某个人发送一封感恩信。我假设，正如前面的例子一样，大多数人误解了这封信会对接收者产生的影响。对于奥尼先生，对我来说这也是其中的一部分，因为已经过去这么多年了，突然接触感觉会很奇怪。经常阻碍我们的是我们对对方可能如何反应的担忧或焦虑。我到底会
You once ran a study where you asked volunteers to send a gratitude letter to someone in their lives. I'm assuming, as in the previous examples, most people misperceived the effect this letter would have on the recipients. That's part of the thing too for me with Mr. Ani is that it's been so many years that reaching out, out of the blue just feels like it's gonna be weird. What often gets in the way is our concern or anxiety about how the other person might respond. What exactly will I
您曾经做过一项研究，要求志愿者给生命中的某个人写一封感谢信。我猜想，就像之前的例子一样，大多数人误判了这封信对收信人的影响。对我来说，关于阿尼先生的事情也是如此，毕竟已经过去这么多年了，突然联系对方会让人觉得很奇怪。通常阻碍我们的是对对方反应的担忧或焦虑。我到底会
say? Will I get the words just right? So the depth of appreciation that I feel for Mr. Ani is so intense. Am I going to say that right? Or is it not going to do it justice? So there are all these fears or anxieties that we have about how well we'll be able to do this that sometimes hold us back. And what we find is that when we ask people to actually do this, whether it's my MBA students here at the University of Chicago who have asked to do this in a class demonstration for years now, or just folks out there in the world we asked to do this, people tend to underestimate how positively
说出来？我能把话说得恰到好处吗？我对阿尼先生的感激之情是如此强烈。我能表达得当吗？还是说这样做还不够？所以，我们对能否做好这件事总是心存恐惧或焦虑，有时这反而阻碍了我们。我们发现，当我们真正要求人们去做这件事时，无论是芝加哥大学MBA的学生（他们多年来一直在课堂演示中这样做），还是我们要求世界各地的普通人这样做，人们往往低估了
their recipient is gonna respond. They recognize it'll be great, but it turns out this is like one of the best letters you'll ever receive in your life. ["The Last Supper"] Next, research shows that we systematically underestimate how much we will enjoy connecting with people and how meaningful our outreach will feel to others. But no matter how many times we see this, no matter how many times the data confirms this, it can still feel as though we'd be better off keeping to ourselves.
对方的积极回应程度。他们意识到这会很棒，但事实证明，这可能是你一生中收到的最好的信件之一。[《最后的晚餐》] 接下来，研究表明，我们系统性地低估了与人建立联系的乐趣，也低估了我们的主动接触对他人而言有多么重要。但无论我们看到多少次这种情况，无论数据证实了多少次，我们仍然会觉得独处会更好。
When we come back, how to combat our false intuitions? You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Nicholas Epley is a psychologist at the University of Chicago Booth School of Business. His research suggests that every day we have a choice to make. Do we strike up a conversation with the person sitting next to us on the train or plane? Or do we keep our eyes fixed on our phones and laptops? Do we offer compliments and gratitude to the people who matter in our lives? Or do we assume that they already know how we feel? Do we keep our views on sensitive
稍后回来，我们将探讨如何克服错误的直觉。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》（Hidden Brain）。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam）。尼古拉斯·埃普利（Nicholas Epley）是芝加哥大学布斯商学院的心理学家。他的研究表明，我们每天都要做出选择。我们是该和坐在火车或飞机旁边的人搭话，还是盯着手机和笔记本电脑？我们是该向生命中重要的人表达赞美和感激，还是认为他们已经知道我们的感受？我们是该把对敏感
topics to ourselves or open ourselves up to difficult but meaningful conversation? Nick, you said that we face what you call approach or avoid decisions all the time in social life. What do you mean by this and what is your advice? So I think of this as the choice, not just every day of our lives, but depending on where we are and what we're doing, sometimes every hour of our lives, every five minutes of our lives.
话题的看法藏在心里，还是敞开心扉进行艰难但有意义的对话？尼克，你说过我们在社交生活中一直面临所谓的“接近或回避”决策。你这是什么意思？你有什么建议？我认为这是一种选择，不仅是每天，而且根据我们所处的位置和正在做的事情，有时甚至是每小时、每五分钟都要面对的选择。
And these choices, these social choices, often involve a tension between the desire to approach, to connect, but also the fears we have that sometimes lead us to avoid other people. This approach avoidance dynamic is fundamental to our motivation. We see this across species. This is kind of how our motivation works, is a tension between these two systems in our own brains. And what we find in our research is that the inputs into those two motivational systems tilts us more towards avoidance than I think would be optimal for us.
这些选择，这些社交选择，往往涉及一种张力：既渴望接近、建立联系，又因恐惧而导致我们回避他人。这种“接近-回避”的动力是动机的基础。我们在不同物种中都能看到这一点。我们的动机运作方式就是大脑中这两个系统之间的张力。我们的研究发现，这两个动机系统的输入往往使我们比预想中更倾向于回避，而这并非最佳状态。
So you say that we can push back against being under social by actively looking for what you call affordances. These are opportunities to become more social. You recently identified an affordance for social interaction when a pear tree on your property needed picking. Tell me the story, Nick. Yeah. So I've got a little orchard behind our house. We've got one tree in particular. It's an Asian pear tree.
所以你说，我们可以通过积极寻找所谓的“可供性”（affordances）来抵制社交不足。这些就是变得更善于社交的机会。你最近在自家院子里的梨树需要采摘时，发现了一个社交互动的机会。讲讲这个故事吧，尼克。好的。我家后面有个小果园。我们有一棵特别的树，是一棵亚洲梨树。
It just pours through. We get wheelbarrows full of Asian pears in the fall and they're great, but they're also a pain in the neck because there are like 500 of these things. And so most years we'd pick all these pears and then we would have, you know, wheelbarrows and buckets full of Asian pears that we would try to eat for months as best we could. And then there were hundreds that we would try to give away to people. This last fall though, we invited essentially the whole neighborhood over for a pair picking party.
它结的果子多得惊人。秋天我们能收获满满几独轮车的亚洲梨，它们很棒，但也让人头疼，因为有大约500个之多。所以大多数年份，我们摘完梨后，会有几独轮车和几桶梨，我们尽可能地吃上几个月。还有几百个我们试图送人。不过去年秋天，我们邀请了几乎整个社区的人来参加采摘派对。
And I have a tractor that's got a bucket on it. We brought that to the house and I was lifting the kids up into the tree in the bucket and we had a ladder up into the tree that kids were climbing up and everybody had buckets. We spent hours, kids playing with each other on our trampoline, we just turned it into a party. And it turned that experience that otherwise would have been kind of arduous and isolating into one that was really, really fun.
我有一辆带斗的拖拉机。我们把它开到房子后面，我用斗把孩子们举到树上，我们还架了梯子，孩子们爬上去，每个人都拿着桶。我们花了几个小时，孩子们在蹦床上玩耍，我们把它变成了一个派对。这把原本可能既艰苦又孤立的体验，变成了一次非常、非常有趣的经历。
So when it comes to strangers, not neighbors, not friends, not relatives, but strangers, the hardest part of reaching out is often the moment of reaching out. Talk a moment about how we can get over that hump. An illustrative example comes from this great experiment, one I just love, from Gillian Sandstrom, Erica Boothby and Gus Cooney, where they had people play a scavenger hunt over the course of a week. They were shown a whole bunch of different challenges. People that they were to identify and were asked to go out and have a conversation with.
那么，当涉及到陌生人时——不是邻居、朋友或亲戚，而是陌生人——主动接触最难的部分往往就是那一瞬间。谈谈我们如何克服那个障碍吧。一个很好的例子来自吉莉安·桑德斯特罗姆（Gillian Sandstrom）、埃里卡·布斯比（Erica Boothby）和格斯·库尼（Gus Cooney）的一项我很喜欢的实验，他们让人们在一周内玩寻宝游戏。他们被展示了一系列不同的挑战。他们需要识别出特定的人，并被要求去和这些人交谈。
So top hat was one. Find somebody with a hat, go have a conversation with. So top hat was one, find somebody with a hat, go have a conversation with them. Manscape, find somebody with a beard, go have a conversation with them. And what they found over the course of this week was that people enjoyed these conversations more than they expected.
比如“高礼帽”就是一个挑战。找到一个戴帽子的人，去和他们交谈。比如“蓄须”就是一个挑战，找到一个留胡子的人，去和他们交谈。他们在这一周里发现，人们从这些对话中获得的乐趣比预期的要多。
And over the course of the week they learned, but they also found more opportunities for engaging with other people over the course of the week than they had at the beginning of the week. Once you start looking for social afforenses, ways to reach out and connect with people, once you start taking an interest in other people, I think opportunities start to emerge, opportunities you wouldn't have thought of before. And that I think involves or requires just changing your mindset a little bit.
在这一周里，他们不仅学到了东西，还发现与他人互动的机会比刚开始时更多。一旦你开始寻找社交机会，寻找接触和联系他人的方式，一旦你开始对他人产生兴趣，我认为机会就会开始出现，那些你以前从未想过的机会。我认为这需要稍微改变一下心态。
Once you start taking an interest in other people, paying attention to them, opportunities to engage will crop up. You'll notice a shirt that you can compliment somebody on. You'll notice that somebody's got a sticker on their backpack from a place you visited that you can ask them about. You'll realize, like I do in the morning when I'm walking, that if I see somebody's door open,
一旦你开始对他人产生兴趣，关注他们，互动的机会就会涌现。你会注意到某人的衬衫，可以夸奖一下；你会注意到某人的背包上贴着你去过的地方的贴纸，可以问问他们。你会意识到，就像我每天早上散步时那样，如果我看到某人的门开着，
that's a chance for me to say hi to them and just lift up that start of their day just a little bit more. You'll start seeing things that you hadn't seen before. I certainly do in my own life. So that's one, I think, important first step. So when we do manage to get over the hump and talk to strangers, we often restrict ourselves to small talk.
那对我来说就是一个打招呼的机会，能让他们的这一天稍微美好一点。你会开始看到以前没看到的东西。我在自己的生活中确实如此。所以我认为这是重要的一步。那么，当我们成功克服障碍并与陌生人交谈时，我们往往局限于闲聊。
We talk about sports, we talk about the weather. You say that this can sometimes be a mistake, and in fact, you've run experiments on making a choice between small talk and deep talk. What do you find, Nick? Well, like many of these social situations where you have to think about, do I reach out and approach this person or avoid? Once you've decided to approach somebody, once you're having a conversation with somebody,
我们谈论体育，谈论天气。你说这有时是个错误，事实上，你还做过关于在“闲聊”和“深度交流”之间做出选择的实验。你发现了什么，尼克？嗯，就像许多社交场合一样，你必须考虑：我是该主动接近这个人，还是回避？一旦你决定接近某人，一旦你正在和某人交谈，
you have to decide what to talk about, right? So when you ask people, the word small talk and hate are often in close proximity to each other. Nobody likes small talk. And yet we find ourselves doing a lot of it. And what we find in our work is that stems not so much from not wanting to have deeper conversations when you ask people to generate topics of conversation that are deeper than they normally do, they come up with some pretty good stuff. They'll ask people, you know, what do you regret most in your life?
你必须决定谈论什么，对吧？当你问人们时，“闲聊”和“讨厌”这两个词往往紧密相连。没人喜欢闲聊。然而我们发现自己做了很多闲聊。我们的研究发现，这并不是因为人们不想进行更深入的对话。当你要求人们提出比平时更深入的对话话题时，他们能想出一些非常好的内容。他们会问别人，比如，你一生中最后悔的是什么？
Or what do you want to be known for? What are you most proud of? They come up with meaningful stuff. That doesn't seem to be too hard. Instead the barrier seems to be anxiety about what will happen if I actually open up and ask this deep stuff. And this, again, is misplaced fear to some extent. We find that they think it's gonna be more awkward
或者你想以什么而闻名？你最引以为傲的是什么？他们能提出有意义的话题。这似乎并不太难。相反，障碍似乎是对“如果我真的敞开心扉问这些深刻的问题会发生什么”的焦虑。这在某种程度上又是错位的恐惧。我们发现，他们认为这会比实际情况更尴尬。
than it actually is. They think they'll have less in common with another person than they find themselves to have. And they think they'll enjoy it less than they actually do. Have you ever had these conversations or attempted a conversation or attempted to launch into a deep topic and been rebuffed, Nick? and they think they'll enjoy it less than they actually do. Have you ever had these conversations or attempted a conversation or attempted to launch into a deep topic and being rebuffed, Nick?
他们认为自己和对方的共同点比实际发现的要少。他们认为自己从中获得的乐趣比实际要少。尼克，你有没有过这些对话，或者尝试过对话，或者试图开启一个深刻的话题却被拒绝了？他们认为自己从中获得的乐趣比实际要少。尼克，你有没有过这些对话，或者尝试过对话，或者试图开启一个深刻的话题却被拒绝了？
I can't think of one. I've asked other people this too, and people often can't think of them. So it's not that I can't imagine it happening. I can imagine it happening, but let me give you an example from my train ride just the other morning. There's a man sitting on the second level of the train
我想不出一个例子。我也问过其他人，人们通常也想不出。所以并不是我无法想象这种情况发生。我可以想象它发生，但让我给你举个例子，就在前几天早上坐火车时。有一个男人坐在火车的二层，
on the side. I'd seen him before, once before, and he looks just sharp as could be. Wearing a bow tie and a suit, he was killing it. And I told him that. I said, you look awesome today. Whatever you're doing, you're gonna nail it. And I told him that. I said, you look awesome today, whatever you're doing, you're gonna nail it. And I asked him, would you be up for talking this morning?
靠边坐着。我以前见过他一次，他看起来非常干练。戴着领结，穿着西装，看起来棒极了。我告诉了他。我说，你今天看起来太棒了。无论你在做什么，你都会成功的。我告诉了他。我说，你今天看起来太棒了，无论你在做什么，你都会成功的。我问他，今天早上愿意聊聊吗？
And he said, yeah, of course. And I introduced myself. And then I just said, tell me about yourself. Why are you here and what are you doing? And it turned right away from kind of a trivial conversation we could have had to having him tell me about difficult upbringing he'd had
他说，当然愿意。我做了自我介绍。然后我就说，跟我说说你自己吧。你为什么在这里，你在做什么？对话立刻从我们可能进行的琐碎闲聊，转变为他向我讲述他艰难的成长经历，
on the South side of Chicago, this program he'd gotten into that really turned his life around, difficulties he had with his father towards the end of his life, this amazing job opportunity he got at Northwestern on the North side of town. And it happened because I took an interest in him.
在芝加哥南区，他参加的那个真正改变了他生活的项目，他父亲在生命最后阶段他所面临的困难，以及他在城北西北大学获得的那份令人惊叹的工作机会。这一切的发生，仅仅是因为我对他产生了兴趣。
And when you take an interest in another person, you're really genuinely interested in them, they tend to open up back to you. I cannot think of a time where I've tried to really connect meaningfully with somebody in conversation and they've said no. And you actually recommend that when people have these conversations, they try and reach for a deep question sooner rather than later. Yeah, so psychologists have long shared the intuition
当你对另一个人产生兴趣，真正地对他们感兴趣时，他们往往会向你敞开心扉。我想不出有哪次我试图与某人进行有意义的对话，而对方拒绝了我。你实际上建议人们在进行这些对话时，尽量尽早提出深刻的问题。是的，心理学家长期以来一直有一种直觉，
that I think most of us do too, which is that deep stuff, finding out what really matters to somebody or what's really important to them, that you cannot really only talk about that to a friend. You can't engage new folks with that quickly. It takes a long runway. Right?
我想我们大多数人也有，那就是：深刻的东西，找出对某人真正重要的事情，你不能只和朋友谈论这些。你不能很快地与陌生人进行这种交流。这需要很长的跑道。对吧？
So I guess 747 taking off, you just, you got to run slow along the ground for a while before you raise your intimacy level. It's like taking the stairs to the top of the Empire State Building. That's what we think of it as. But I don't think that's quite right. I think you can press the elevator to a more meaningful and deep floor pretty quickly, get right up to the top without beating around the bush a lot. And I see it happen over and over again in my conversations.
就像波音747起飞一样，你必须在地面上慢慢滑行一段时间，才能提高亲密度。这就像走楼梯到帝国大厦顶端。我们是这么认为的。但我认为这不太对。我认为你可以直接按电梯到更深刻的楼层，很快就能到达顶端，而不必绕圈子。我在自己的对话中一次又一次地看到这种情况发生。
You take an interest in somebody, you ask about something they really care about, they're happy to talk to you about it typically. So once at a gathering of high level financial folks, you decided to see what would happen if you asked the executives to have deep conversations with one another. How did the exercise play out, Nick?
你对某人产生兴趣，询问他们真正关心的事情，他们通常很乐意和你谈论这些。那么，有一次在高级金融人士的聚会上，你决定看看如果要求高管们进行深度对话会发生什么。尼克，这个练习是怎么进行的？
Yeah, so this was the very first time I tested experimentally in a very public setting. What happens when people go deep quickly in conversation? I was at a conference at a hedge fund in Connecticut, standing in front of a room of just a little over 50 people, all like super serious banker types. They were all, you know, wearing suits I could never have afforded. I kind of thought I'd been brought in as the sideshow for this math heavy quant jock kind of decision making conference. And I decided that I was going to run an experiment with them where I had them have a deep and
是的，这是我第一次在一个非常公开的场合进行实验测试。当人们在对话中迅速深入时会发生什么？当时我在康涅狄格州的一家对冲基金会议上，站在50多人的房间前面，全都是非常严肃的银行家类型。他们都穿着我买不起的西装。我当时以为我只是被请来作为这个数学密集型量化决策会议的“配菜”。我决定和他们做一个实验，让他们和别人进行一次深刻而
meaningful conversation with somebody else. That instead of doing the slow runway up to something deep and meaningful, we're going to start right away with something deep and meaningful. So I told them, in just a minute, I'm going to pair you up with somebody else in this room. They didn't know each other. And I put four questions up on the screen. Things like, if I was going to become a good friend of yours, what would be most important
有意义的对话。不是慢慢铺垫到深刻有意义的话题，而是直接开始。所以我告诉他们，一会儿我会把你们和房间里的其他人配对。他们互不认识。我在屏幕上放了四个问题。比如，如果我要成为你的好朋友，什么对我来说最重要？
for me to know about you? If a crystal ball could tell you anything about the future, what would you want to know? And the last question I had up there was, can you tell me about one of the last times you cried in front of another person? Wow. Yeah, wow. So as soon as I put these up on the screen, it felt like, you know, somebody just sucked the air
如果水晶球能告诉你关于未来的任何事情，你想知道什么？我放的最后一个问题是：你能告诉我你最后一次在别人面前哭是什么时候吗？哇。是的，哇。当我把这些放在屏幕上时，感觉就像有人把房间里的空气
right out of the room. These people were not enthused, right? These were like my kids here, and we're going to do the compliment calendar for Christmas this year. They did not want to do this. A guy in the front swore. He said, oh, and then issued an expletive as soon as he saw the words up on the screen. Everybody else started kind of rumbling and grumbling. I felt like I was in a canoe right at the top of a waterfall and I was just seeing over the edge and this was going to go downhill fast. I tried to play it cool on the outside, but I was nervous this could be on the inside. I pushed forward and told them we're going to pair them up and we did, gave them cards
抽干了一样。这些人并不热衷，对吧？他们就像我这里的孩子，我们今年圣诞节要制作赞美日历。他们不想这样做。前排的一个人骂了一句。他说，哦，看到屏幕上的字时，他爆了粗口。其他人开始窃窃私语。我觉得自己就像在瀑布顶端的独木舟上，我能看到边缘，事情很快就会急转直下。我表面上尽量保持冷静，但内心很紧张。我继续推进，告诉他们我们要进行配对，我们确实这样做了，给了他们卡片，
with these questions on it and let them go. And I was just a nervous wreck about this. Most of these people, you know, like 85% of them were men, super serious, older folks who did not come to this conference to bear their soul to some other person. But after a few minutes, the room just, it's like I'd flipped a switch on their backs or something. They kind of started coming to life.
上面写着这些问题，让他们开始。我当时紧张得要命。这些人中，大约85%是男性，非常严肃，年长的人，他们来参加这个会议可不是为了向别人倾诉灵魂。但几分钟后，房间里就像我按下了开关一样。他们开始活跃起来。
They were laughing with each other and I was gonna let them talk for 10 minutes, but at 10 minutes, the room was very loud. Everybody was talking. They were having a good time and there was no way I was gonna get them out of those conversations. About five minutes later, I started shouting
他们互相大笑，我本来打算让他们谈10分钟，但10分钟后，房间里非常吵。每个人都在说话。他们玩得很开心，我根本没法让他们停止对话。大约5分钟后，我开始对着麦克风大喊，
into my microphone that we had just a few minutes left. I finally was able to corral them at about 20 minutes by doing a trick I heard from my kid's kindergarten teacher, counting down very loudly from five. When you hit one, they usually are quiet. And so I had to do that. And what was just startling to me was the shift in the feeling in that room from the start of it, which was just absolute dread, to the end where I could hardly pull them apart. There was one group I saw where one of the two guys was in tears. I saw another guy hugging another guy at the end of their session. Everybody was shaking hands with what they left. The whole mood in that room brightened. That move
说我们只剩下几分钟了。我终于在20分钟左右通过一个从我孩子幼儿园老师那里学来的技巧把他们召集起来：大声从五倒数到一。数到一时，他们通常会安静下来。所以我不得不这样做。让我震惊的是，房间里的气氛从开始时的绝对恐惧，转变为结束时我几乎无法将他们分开。我看到一组人，其中一个人流下了眼泪。我看到另一个人在会议结束时拥抱了对方。每个人离开时都在握手。整个房间的气氛都明亮了。那种从
from dread to delight at the end. I'd never seen anything like that happen. That kind of switch. After the conversation, I had them tell me how it actually felt, and the gap between the expectations before and the experiences after were massive. Booth School of Business. He's the author of Mind Wise, Why We Misunderstand What Others Think, Believe, Feel, and Want. Nick, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thanks, Shankar. If you have follow-up questions for Nick Epley that you'd be willing to share with members of the Hidden Brain audience,
恐惧到喜悦的转变，我从未见过。那种转变。对话结束后，我让他们告诉我真实的感受，之前的预期和之后的体验之间的差距是巨大的。布斯商学院。他是《思维智慧：为什么我们误解他人的想法、信念、感受和欲望》（Mind Wise）的作者。尼克，非常感谢你今天参加《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢，尚卡尔。如果你有后续问题想与《隐藏的大脑》的听众分享，
please record a voice memo on your phone and email it to us at ideas at hiddenbrain.org. That email address again is ideas at hiddenbrain.org. Sixty seconds is plenty and please use the subject line connecting. If you want to write out a question, please be sure to tell us how to pronounce your name. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quirrell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. If you love the ideas we bring you on Hiddenbrain, please consider joining our podcast subscription, Hiddenbrain+.
请在手机上录制语音备忘录并发送电子邮件至 ideas@hiddenbrain.org。再次重复邮箱地址：ideas@hiddenbrain.org。60秒就足够了，请使用主题行“connecting”。如果你想写下问题，请务必告诉我们如何发音你的名字。《隐藏的大脑》由《隐藏的大脑》媒体制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲-保罗（Annie Murphy-Paul）、克里斯汀·王（Kristen Wong）、劳拉·奎雷尔（Laura Quirrell）、瑞安·卡茨（Ryan Katz）、奥特姆·巴恩斯（Autumn Barnes）、安德鲁·查德威克（Andrew Chadwick）和尼克·伍德伯里（Nick Woodbury）。塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。如果你喜欢我们在《隐藏的大脑》中带来的观点，请考虑加入我们的播客订阅：HiddenBrain+。
It's where you'll find conversations you won't hear anywhere else, along with our segment, Your Questions Answered, where we bring back guests to respond to your follow-up questions about their work. To try a seven-day free trial of Hidden Brain Plus, go to apple.co. slash hiddenbrain or support.hiddenbrain.org. We truly appreciate your interest in our work. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. You There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在那里你会找到你在其他任何地方都听不到的对话，以及我们的栏目“你的问题已解答”（Your Questions Answered），我们会请回嘉宾来回答你关于他们工作的后续问题。要试用七天的Hidden Brain Plus免费试用，请访问 apple.co/hiddenbrain 或 support.hiddenbrain.org。我们非常感谢你对我们工作的关注。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。很快再见。目前还没有关于这一集的评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。